Yes, is infrared light or red light therapy okay for bone metastasis, bone metastatic
bone cancer? Not sure about both or one of them. I hear some can cause circulation, blood
flow and not necessarily good for tumors. So yeah, I don't know that I would use near or far
infrared over a bone cancer. It's really hard because, okay, so there's, yes, if you look
at the data for infrared light or red light therapy, the data is that the reason why it helps it heals
and it increases circulation to the area. For an overall physiological picture, that's how your
body heals. You increase circulation, brings oxygen, brings nutrients, it helps heal tissue.
Well, you don't want to necessarily increase circulation around the cancer in one sense of the
word and increase cancer's ability to metabolize. However, if you heat a cancer, it is far less stable
than healthy tissue. So in that sense, using infrared therapy over a cancer can actually help your
body kill the cancer because your cells, your healthy cells are very stable to increase temperature
to a certain degree. You're not going to have tissue break down until you get to maybe 106, 107
degrees Fahrenheit, whereas cancer cells can die at 102 degrees Fahrenheit. So that's a side benefit
of like that has been pushed personas. But I'm always said, really the chance of you really raising
your body temperature up to 102 degrees Fahrenheit while you're in a sauna is probably pretty slim.
You could take your oral temperature before you go to the sauna and take it right after you get
out of the sauna and see if there's that much of a change in total body temperature. Most cancers
are fairly deep and out of the skin. So I don't know that that would be really a benefit of a sauna.
Now, if you're using a true infrared light, there's a lot of infrared lights on the market
that, you know, it's a bulb, but infrared light bulb that you screw into any socket and
you could put that near your tissue. It's a red light and it's sold as an infrared light. But in truth,
there is literally no infrared coming out of there, infrared by definition, whether it be near
or far or mixed infrared, it's not going to be visible. So it's not in the visible light spectrum.
So you won't see a light. So we have our hyperthermia units. You don't see a light
because it's a true infrared heat source. So it's heating deep and it goes through the tissue.
It has to be a drug skin content contact and it will go down an inch or a little bit more,
maybe an inch and a half, but it's not going to go a whole lot deeper than that. So it's still only
beneficial to kill cancer that's fairly near the surface. So if I have, you know, cancer that's
metastasized to my pelvis, the chance that infrared light is going to get deep enough to
raise the core temperature to kill cancer cells is pretty slim. If I've had my breast or near
right near the surface of my tissue, yeah, it certainly possibly can. Or if it's in, you know,
a bone that's right near the surface, let's say it's in a, the slightest process of your,
your lumbar spine. Yeah, you could probably for sure get it added with a true infrared source.
But again, we're talking about a true infrared source of light, not one of those bulbs you could
buy on the market, a true infrared source of light is going to be their, their expensive little
tools are about $5,000. Red light therapy is just using different colors that affect the skin.
That doesn't go deep at all. It's, but it's going to use colors that will affect the skin
and affect the tissues. I don't see any problem with using just a red light therapy
machine at all. They can be very beneficial. There's, they're making physiological changes not
directly, but from a reflex reaction in your body's physiology. And then there's another type of
light therapy called laser therapy. So laser, there's actually four different classes of laser.
Most of the lasers on the market, let's say that a car proctor might have would be a
level two or level three or maybe a level three B laser. The level four lasers are the most
powerful lasers. Those are the lasers. If you could put a fitted apparatus on it, it comes out as
a pinpoint beam that would actually cut tissue. That's what you'd use for surgery. But as a wide
beam, it can be extremely healing. So laser therapy, it can be very healing. Now there is
controversy whether you should use a three B or level four laser with cancer. Because if it's
healing, could it actually increase the metabolic rate and heal and keep a cancer alive?
So all the laser companies have a caveat that you're not supposed to use over a cancer or a tumor or
assist. However, I know as several years ago, there was some research coming out of Europe that
was actually showing using laser on a tumor was helping your body heal it and kill the tumor.
Now I've always been afraid to use laser right over a person's breast tumor or over a person's
prostate tumor just because there's just not any data on it. So if a person was in dire straits
and your cancer was going the wrong way, could they do laser? If it was me, I would.
We personally own a class four laser. Class four lasers are super expensive. They're like 45 grand.
But there's, you know, I bought it because I'm addicted to things like that. So
but it's unbelievable for healing, joint issues, disk issues,
sprains, strains, muscle issues, injuries to ligaments, tendons. There's not a lot.
Physical therapies, clinics do not use lasers and the only reason is because
insurance doesn't pay for them. I have a friend who owns who's a part owner of 11 physical therapy
they do not use laser in their clinics because they don't get any insurance reimbursement.
In physical therapy, clinics by the way are 100% financially driven by insurance reimbursement.
They don't get they don't get self paid patients. So they charge, you know, on $400 or $500
and visit, it's all charged to insurance. So there's a therapy that doesn't get covered by
insurance. They don't do it. That's the only reason why they don't do it. So you have to find a
clinic that has a, if you use a level two laser, it's really not going to do anything. So that's
to be a level three B or a level four laser. That's the only good lasers on the market. So
it's something you could certainly try. I, you know, the, the danger is is that
would it cause the tumor to grow? There's just no data. Nobody's ever done it.
I know the studies that there was a couple of studies that were published in Spain, I believe,
but that was a while ago. That was even eight, ten years ago. They were very positive.
They were using them for cancers over there. But understand that's when Europe was much more open
to alternative things. Medical fields in Europe had shut down just as bad as the FDA had shut down
things here. The pharmaceutical companies have basically taken over pretty much the world.
And all the countries medical, you know, like the FDA's of every company. So
do that kind of research is just not going to come out anymore. So
if I was in a situation where my cancer was growing crazily and I tried everything else,
I would certainly do the laser over it. It's like it's worth a shot. If I was doing pretty well
and, you know, I'm just thinking of another therapy to add, I don't know that I would necessarily do
it. I would not be afraid of infrared or red light therapy over bullying metastasis.
So I, you know, obviously with anything you just go slow and you make sure you're,
you know, going to change to stronger, we change in science and symptoms.